damaris is with us damaris is in new
york city hi damaris how are you
hi i'm doing well thank you so much for
taking my call
my pleasure how can we help
my husband and i currently have about
113 000
in debt which just does not include our
home we have
um approximately ten thousand days and
savings for
emergencies in case anything happens
with the home
we have our son and we're about to start
foster caring
and we're just we've been living simple
we've paid off twenty seven thousand
dollars in credit cards so those are
gone
good and we're just yeah we're just
trying to decide
do we pay use the ten thousand dollars
to help pay towards the debt and bring
us down to the 1000
emergency fund um being that you know we
have a home that we have
our someone in us to enforce a child
we're not we're just not really sure
if we should save that money um uh
or you know use that towards so what is
the 113 000 in debt
we have uh about 19 000 or so in a car
loan and then
94 000 student loans between my husband
and i and what's your household income
uh currently my husband makes 68 i am
making
unfortunately 12 000 a year um i used to
make a lot more but
uh one coveted i lost my job and
um i used to make fifty two thousand
okay when
well i'm a bookkeeper so i've been
looking for work on the bookkeeping job
but most jobs now want a degree and i
don't have
i didn't get to finish school i don't
have my degree yet
um new york city a non-degree bookkeeper
can make 52 with experience
yeah i'm actually in doable jersey yeah
but i mean this still it's still
that same market that's doable um it's
not it's not instantaneous but i mean
your life did not end because you didn't
have the only job in new jersey
that someone paid 52 000 for bookkeeping
that's just for a non-degree bookkeeper
that's not true they're
they're there so that's good the good
news is you're going to be back if you
want to be are you going to go back
oh i've been looking since october for
in conjunction with bishop i was working
actually three jobs at one time just
because i want to get a you know take
care of family but now i'm
making now those two others fell off uh
they ended
the contract ended um and so i'm still
looking
um i even started doing doordash just to
get money coming in while i'm looking
okay i'll tell you what i i want you to
go to kencoleman.com
ken is one of our ramsey personalities
that does a show on sirius and
and on 75 radio stations across america
he's not in your market
but he's one of our team members here
and he teaches people how to land jobs
and how to how to focus on their career
there's tons of free resources there
on landing a job and doing a more
effective
efficient job search than the
traditional job search okay he's going
to help you a bunch with that i'm going
to give you a copy of his book
free it's called the proximity principle
but it's ken
coleman dot com now when you land that
job it's going to lower your fear
substantially
you're kind of in a medium-sized storm
and i'm not sure you should be on the
baby steps right now you might should
push
pause and you guys just pile up as much
cash as you can pile up and then you
land that job
and then you clean out that account and
go down to a thousand dollars and start
baby step
one baby step two immediately tearing
into this debt
again
i'm sorry we were doing really well and
then this happened so you know
yeah and um that's how we pick up the
27k before so
you lost almost half your household
income
yes is now a great time to be fostering
sounds like there's a lot of stress and
a lot of heat in that home
and man fostering it's such a it's such
an
honorable thing to do and it is hard
it is hard um you know we played about
it and uh we were um
uh put on hold because of covert and
then uh just
literally three or four weeks ago they
called us saying hey
are you so interested and in our hearts
we've always wanted to and we just felt
like if they're calling us it's god's
timing
and we're really happy i mean god knows
we have food on a plate we're very
blessed we're happy with what we have
and just trying to you know be thankful
and
if we can help another child um in this
situation
that's that's kind of where our heart is
at yeah i get that in that i hear
i hear you yeah that was what yeah i
want to always go back and this is a
an over an overdone um
analogy but you got to put your oxygen
mask on first
before you put your oxygen mask on your
kids and you guys got to be healthy your
marriage has to be good you got to knock
this
dead out you've got to figure out what
you want to do with employment or stay
at home
sounds like a lot of moving pieces and
to bring a kid into that
intentionally man it's so it's a it's a
it's a
wonderful thing to do but man it's gonna
just add another layer a big layer
of weight into that home yeah agreed
okay so push pause and pile up cash on
the money piece
go to kingcoleman.com hold on kelly i'll
give you a copy of proximity principle i
want you to land that job super fast
and then i want you to push play which
means you are going down to a thousand
dollars
and you're going to put everything on
the debt and you're going to list your
debt smallest largest and you're going
to pay off 113 000 in 36 months
and you're going to be 100 debt free
three years from today
but that's how your process is going to
go down but you don't want to half do it
and say i'm going to keep the 10 and
then i'm going to keep paying on the
debt now let's either let's either say
it's a storm
and we're on pause and we're piling up
cash or we're down to a thousand dollars
and we're game on
whichever it is i think you're in the
middle of a storm and you hadn't really
calculated that because you lost half
your annual income
that's what it sounds like